here's what to do if you have clients
whose payments are declining and they're
not finishing out payment plans there's
two things the first thing is that you
actually have to get the customer to
fill out the application for the payment
plan if they fill it out they feel
actively more ownership over the
decision the second thing you do if
before you sign up for a payment plan
for something that's really expensive
the sales person asks you hey are you
the type of person who sticks with your
commitment the reason they're asking you
that is a psychological thing called
commitment consistency which is if they
give you a label that's positive you'll
associate with that label and then be
far more likely to actually own the
commitment or decision that you're
making and it's so that you don't
decline or default on the payment in the
future you can also use that as a
salesperson in Reverse to get more
people to stick with the commitments
that they're buying it's one of those
easy psychological switches that can
make you more money if you like that
video like follow and comment I'll see
in the next